[MUSIC PLAYING]
- I would like to bring
up James Santangelo, who
is a graduate student
in evolutionary biology
at the University of Toronto.
And James is going to tell
us about rapid evolution
in urban settings using the
white clover as a model.
[APPLAUSE]
- Awesome.
So thanks for having me here
to talk to you guys today.
So I'm going to tell you
a little bit about some
of the work I've been
doing trying to understand
how species evolve in
response to urbanization
as part of my PhD.
So as I'm sure
many are familiar,
we're part of this new
epoch now that geologists
refer to as the Anthropocene,
in which human beings are having
a decisive impact on the state,
dynamic, and future of planet
Earth.
Now, much of these
changes are being
driven by urbanization, in
which huge swaths of Earth's
natural landscapes
are being converted
into human settlements like
towns, villages, and cities.
And prior to 1990, the
traditional view of cities
was that they were
very much anti-life.
Looking at a dense, smoggy
metropolis like this,
how could it support
levels of biodiversity
that would make it
interesting or worthy
of study from a
biologist's standpoint?
And this is a serious
problem, because of course,
urban environments are
distributed across the world.
As of 2008, the majority
of the human population
lives in cities, and
urban environments
continue to expand
across the world.
And so there's a pressing
need to understand
how species are
evolving or adapting
in response to these
changes, and whether we're
going to be able to recover some
of the species that are most
at risk.
And so an emerging view is that
cities are living laboratories
of biological investigation.
And I think this view is
emerging for three reasons.
The first is because of the
scale of urban environments
that allows us to use
independent cities peppered
across the world to
test interesting ideas
in evolutionary biology.
The second is because
work by urban ecologists
since the 1990s have
found that, rather
than decimating
biodiversity, cities
harbor unique
biological communities
and altered ecological
interactions.
And so we know a lot about
how cities are influencing
the ecology of
species, but we still
know very little about
how they're influencing
the evolution of species.
And finally, relative to
some of the other stuff
we've been hearing about
today, urbanization
is a really recent phenomenon.
In the Americas, for
example, it dates back
but a few hundred years.
And so any evolution
that we see in cities
is really rapid evolution that,
prior to a few decades ago,
was thought to be impossible.
And so we now recognize
that evolution in cities
could happen in four main
ways, which I've broken up here
into non-adaptive and
adaptive mechanisms.
So the first, of course, is
mutation, whereby, for example,
urban pollution causes
individual mutations
at the level of
individual-based substitutions
in the genome of organisms
that are living in cities.
This is the one that we
know the least amount about.
The next is gene flow, or the
exchange of genetic information
among populations.
As cities become erected,
and we put barriers in place
like roads and buildings,
this limits the exchange
of genetic information among
populations of species that
refuse to cross those barriers.
And this can have really
pronounced effects
on the evolution
of those species.
The next is genetic
drift, where you
have an ancestrally
large population
with a ton of genetic
variation that
then gets fragmented into
a small population because
of the construction of a city,
and that small population now
contains only a small subset
of that initial variation.
And then finally we
have the mechanism
that most people
are familiar with,
natural selection,
or the differential
reproductive success
of individuals
leading to the survival of
some at the expense of others.
Throughout my talk, I'm going to
focus on these three mechanisms
here.
And I'm going to do so
using the model system
white clover that's been
the focus of my PhD.
White clover is
an excellent model
for understanding the impacts
of urbanization on evolution,
because its distribution
overlaps largely
with that of humans.
You'd be hard pressed to
go anywhere in the world
where humans are found
and not find white clover,
and this is because
of its history
in the agricultural
industry of being
seeded into agricultural
pastures for use
as forage and the like.
And so it occurs
on a global scale.
I'm going to focus on
a single trait, which
is the production
of hydrogen cyanide.
This is a trait that's
primarily thought
to be involved in defense
against chewing insects.
And it's populations
of white clover
are polymorphic for
hydrogen cyanide, which
is to say that, in
any one population,
some individuals are
going to produce it,
whereas other
populations are not.
And this is going
to become relevant.
And it's worth taking
a minute to study
the genetics of cyanogenesis.
And it's relatively simple
from a genetic standpoint
relative to some of the other
traits we've heard about today.
We have two genes.
The first gene
encodes the production
of cyanogenic glucosides.
You either have a functional
copy or a non-functional copy.
And I'm abbreviating
this gene as AC.
We then have another
gene, which encodes
the production of a
hydrolyzing enzyme, linamerase.
And again, you could
have a functional copy
or a non-functional copy.
To produce hydrogen
cyanide, individuals
require a functional copy
at both of these genes.
If an individual lacks a
functional copy at either
of these genes, they
lack the ability
to produce hydrogen
cyanide, and they're
what we term acyanogenic.
Now, this phenotype
has a long history
of study in
evolutionary biology,
dating back at least
to 1950s, where
we found
continental-scale patterns
in the frequency of this trait
in Europe, North America, Japan
and New Zealand, such that,
in the southern warmer regions
of the continent, you get
really high frequencies
of hydrogen cyanide
that gradually taper off
as you move north across
the continent, such
that in the north
of Sweden, there's
very little frequencies.
And the change in the
frequency of this trait
across the spatial
gradient is what
I'm going to refer to as a
cline for the rest of this talk.
And this cline is
thought to arise because
of the cost of producing
hydrogen cyanide in really
cold environments where frost
causes the cells to burst,
resulting in hydrogen cyanide
being released in plants that
produce it, and the inadvertent
poisoning of that plant.
And so in really
cold environments
where cells are prone to
breakage due to frost,
there's active selection against
individuals producing hydrogen
cyanide, explaining
their lower frequencies
in the north of Europe.
And so what we're
interested in understanding
is whether the same
processes happening
at a continental scale
could be happening
at the more local
scale across cities,
because of this phenomenon
known as the urban heat island
effect.
Where we know that downtown,
for example in Cambridge where
we are now, it tends
to be quite a bit
warmer than outside of
the city in the more
rural regions pictured here.
And so if the same
processes happening
at a continental scale are
happening on a local scale,
then we might expect
something like this,
where if we plot the
frequency of hydrogen
cyanide on the y-axis, and the
distance to the urban center
on the x-axis, we'd expect
higher frequencies of hydrogen
cyanide in the urban core.
This would be the equivalent
of southern Europe,
and lower frequencies outside
the city, the equivalent
of northern Europe.
And so a previous
master's student
in the lab, Ken Thompson,
was interested in testing
this hypothesis.
So he went to four large North
American cities, Montreal,
Toronto, Boston, and New York.
In each city, he collected
plants from 40 populations
along an urban rural transect.
This is the one spanning
South Boston here.
And in each population, he
quantified the proportion
of plants that were producing
hydrogen cyanide in any one
population.
And he was interested
in understanding
how the proportion of plants
changes as you go from inside
to outside of the city.
And what he found was
the complete opposite
that we predicted,
which is often
really interesting in science.
And so we find that
inside the city,
you actually have much lower
frequencies of hydrogen cyanide
than you do outside the city.
Remarkably, he found
this same pattern
in three out of the four
cities that he assayed.
Now, he tested a bunch
of different mechanisms
that could explain this
pattern, but ultimately settled
on urban-to-rural
snow depth gradients
as being the main cause.
And the interesting thing
here is that, in the winter,
the urban heat
island effect melts
all of the snow on
top of the plants.
And so plants in
the city are then
exposed to the frigid
air temperatures,
resulting in selection
against plants
producing cyanide
in the same way
that we see in northern Europe.
Incidentally, the one city
that didn't show this pattern
was Montreal, which gets so much
snow that no urban heat island
effect can melt all
of it, and so there's
no pattern in Montreal--
pretty clear cut.
There is a problem though,
which is that, one, he only
had a few cities,
and so we don't know
how general this pattern is.
And the second is that all
of those cities get snow.
And so we don't
have a control case.
What's happening in cities that
never get snow or never see
frost?
So I'm going to address the
following three questions
for the remainder of this talk.
The first is, how
repeatable are these clines
across urban rural transects,
along a latitudinal gradient
in eastern North America?
The next is, can we predict
the presence or strength
of these clines based on
regional patterns of snow depth
or minimum winter temperature?
And finally, are there
any other mechanisms
that might explain the presence
of these clines across cities?
So I'll start with
the first question.
At the start of my
degree, what I did was
I went to an
additional 12 cities
in eastern North America, all
the way down to Tampa, Florida,
in each city following the
exact same sampling protocol.
And so to show you some of
that data here, we have,
again, the frequency
of hydrogen cyanide
on the y-axis and the distance
from the urban center.
When we look across all 16
cities for which we have data,
the pattern is clear.
There tends to be, on
average, less hydrogen
cyanide inside the city
than outside the city.
But there's variation
in this, and this
is averaged across 16 cities.
It turns out that eight
out of the 16 cities
showed this pattern, which is
quite remarkable, because we
never see the pattern in the
opposite direction, which
is starting to suggest that
there might be something going
on here.
And I'm going to show you some
of that variation in a minute
when we ask whether or not
we could predict the strength
or presence of these clines
based on regional winter
conditions.
If we could, it might look a
little something like this.
Again, same figure that
we've been looking at.
In northern cities where it
tends to get really cold,
we would expect
really strong clines.
But in more southern
cities where
we don't have that selective
agent, namely frost,
we wouldn't expect
to see it at all.
And so we would expect the
strength of these clines
to decline as we go south
towards the equator.
If we look at the
data, here's a map
of winter temperature
on the background, all
of the cities highlighted here.
What we find is
that in the north,
we indeed do get strong clines.
This is the one in Toronto,
consistent with the hypothesis
that minimum winter
temperatures could be important.
But of course, we actually see
some of our strongest clines
in some of the southern cities.
And so it's starting to look
like something else might
be going on here that we
can't quite explain yet.
And so what's
driving these clines?
So far, the data suggests
that frost and snow
can't be the only
mechanisms, because we
see strong clines in
cities that don't get snow
or don't get frost.
They could be important
in some of the cities,
but it's clearly not
true in all cases.
We know that cities
vary in a lot
of environmental
conditions, and so it's
going to be important
to try to identify
what some of these drivers are.
So I'd like to take a
minute to think about what
other explanations
might drive the repeated
evolution of the same
pattern across space.
And I want to take a
minute to emphasize
the role of neutral
evolutionary processes,
because we've been talking a lot
about natural selection today.
But it turns out that neutral
processes operate quite heavily
in cities because of the
small population sizes
where genes are
fluctuating randomly,
and tend to be lost or fixed in
small populations with greater
probability.
And so remember, the
genetics of this trait
requires that you
have a functional
copy at both of these genes.
That means, if
both of these genes
are fluctuating randomly,
then for this trait
to go up in frequency,
both of the genes
have to go up in
frequency in tandem.
If either of them goes
down in frequency,
then the frequency
of the phenotype
is going to go
down just by chance
alone because of the
fact that you need
both copies in a population.
And so you could
imagine a scenario
where you have a rural
population at equal frequencies
of both of these genes.
As it colonizes
the urban center,
random fluctuations at
either of those two genes
are going to result in the
preferential loss of hydrogen
cyanide, potentially explaining
why we see less hydrogen
cyanide inside the city.
So we tested this by developing
theoretical simulations
of urban evolution, the
first of its kind published
in a special feature
not that long ago.
What we did was, we said,
what if urban populations
tend to be small?
And this is consistent with
much of the literature because
of urban fragmentation
breaking up the landscape,
whereas rural populations
tend to be really large.
We allowed the exchange
of genetic information
between populations, and we
were simply interested in,
how often do we get the
same pattern that we
saw across space just
by neutral processes,
without invoking selection?
And we see that, under really
strong gradients and drift--
so when there's a really big
difference between the size
of urban and rural
populations, you actually
get, on average,
quite strong clines
in the same direction
as the ones that we saw,
suggesting that genetic
drift on its own
could generate the
repeated loss of hydrogen
cyanide inside the
city without ever
invoking natural selection.
As you decrease the
strength of drift,
you get virtually no clines,
which is to be expected,
because the populations
are the same size
across the whole transect.
But of course, as you allow more
and more genetic information
to be exchanged
among populations,
looking only at the
strongest clines,
you see a gradual decrease
in their strength.
And so this alone suggests
that the interplay
between genetic drift, which is
important in small populations
like those in cities,
and gene flow,
could structure
some of the clines
that we're seeing across space.
And so to come back to those
three questions, the first,
how repeatable are these clines?
We see them in eight
out of 16 of the cities
that we've surveyed.
We know that frost could be
important in some of these,
but probably not the
only thing going on,
because we have really
strong clines in some
of the southern cities
that never see frost.
And then genetic drift can cause
these clines on the same order
as those that we
see in the cities,
but we have recent evidence
that suggests that it doesn't.
And I'm not showing
that evidence here,
but we have evidence
from molecular markers,
for example, that shows that,
in the case of clover anyways,
there is no increased strength
of genetic drift in cities.
And so taken together
then, all of these things
point to natural
selection as being
the main driver of the
urban-to-rural clines that we
see across cities.
Frost might be one
of the mechanisms,
but of course, we
see this pattern
in cities that don't
see frost, so we
have to start exploring some
of the other agents that
might be responsible for
driving these patterns.
And so what we really need
is more replication, so more
cities, and we need
these cities to vary
in environmental
conditions in ways
that might allow us to predict
some of these patterns.
And so I'm excited
to say that we've
launched the global
urban evolution
project, which you can read
more about at this URL.
And there's a fantastic
group of people
that are running the
scenes behind the project,
ensuring that everything
runs smoothly.
But I want to highlight the
work of 570 collaborators
from 200 cities
around the world who
are collecting for us 160,000
clover plants from about
7,700 populations.
I want to emphasize that a
lot of these collaborators
are using this as an
opportunity for outreach.
They're engaging
high school students,
undergraduate
students, which I think
highlights the power
of urban evolution
to engage with local
communities and teach people
about evolution.
We're going to be
doing some phenotyping,
so the hydrogen cyanide
assays I mentioned, but also
imaging and remote sensing
of all of these populations,
in addition to generating
genome-wide data to get
a sense of how cities
are driving evolution
across the whole genome rather
than just a small portion
relating to the hydrogen
cyanide phenotype
that I talked about today.
The key questions here, one,
do species convergently adapt
to cities across the world?
So do cities cause
the repeated evolution
of a trait in a single
species across the planet?
And second, what are the
environmental predictors
of that convergent
evolution on a global scale?
And just to give you a sense
of what this looks like,
every point here
represents a city
that's agreed to
collect clover for us.
So we have pretty good
global coverage I would say.
People are really
excited about this.
They're sending us pictures
every day on the Twitter.
And so it's just really
great to see people
sending us pictures of
them doing fieldwork,
and the data sets continue
to flow in on a daily basis.
So pretty soon we're going
to have an answer to this.
And I think projects
like this really
highlight that cities
are living laboratories
to study evolutionary
change because
of their global
replication, and especially
in cases like
white clover, where
we have the same species
occurring across the planet.
And so I would say that
not only is urbanization
a global phenomenon,
but we know now
that urban evolution generally
is a common phenomenon.
And all of the silhouettes
here represent clear-cut cases
where cities have
driven the evolution
in one way or another of the
species that inhabit them.
And the goal is to, as we
accumulate our knowledge of how
cities are influencing the
evolution of life around us,
we can start incorporating
this knowledge
into the design of more
sustainable cities,
and hopefully get a
better sense of how
this rapid environmental
change across the world
is driving changes in
some of the world's
most susceptible species.
And with that, I'd like to thank
my two labs, the University
of Toronto, and of course,
all of the organizers
for inviting me.
I'm going to flip it
back to the picture
here, because it's
more interesting.
And yeah, I'd be happy
to take questions.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
- James, from the
first time I read
about your work in the
New York Times till today,
you did not disappoint.
The white clover rules.
So, there is a question.
Yes?
- Hi.
I was wondering if
geological strata or building
materials are ever a
variable in this at all?
- Wow.
No, not yet.
In what sense?
Are you thinking that
particular strata might--
- Well, yeah.
How it affects soil
composition, and then
how plants might
adapt, not adapt--
- Oh, yeah.
That's an excellent question.
We have a student
in the lab who's
going to be approaching that.
We don't know much
about what's happening
to the soil in the city
relative to outside of the city.
But I really can see
it as being important,
especially because
white clover--
and I didn't mention this--
has a symbiosis with a
particular microbe in its roots
that fixes nitrogen.
And so you could imagine
if soil conditions
change and it influences
the ability of white
clover to form a bond
with this microbe
in the soil, then
that could have
potential impacts for how
it evolves in cities.
But we don't have that data yet.
But that's a really
good question.
- Yes.
- In your southern cities
that show the northern cline
pattern, did you correlate
that with the past winter,
whether they had snow
or other bad weather?
- Yeah, that's a
really good question.
So part of the
problem is that we're
trying to predict these
present clines with relatively
coarse regional
environmental variables.
And so we actually need to do
quite a bit of a better job,
I think, of capturing the
difference between cities
and outside the city.
In that particular
case, the data
comes from Bioclim, which is
averaged from 1950 to 2000.
And so it sort of incorporates
some of those past conditions
as a single point variable.
But yeah, we do need to
do a much better job.
- Do you have any idea how
fast these things vary?
Because if you have snow
in Atlanta last year,
will that change the
population in the spring?
- I think it could.
We know now that
evolution can happen
within a few
generations provided
that the strength of
selection is strong enough.
We don't know whether
that's the case now.
To answer that,
what we really need
is temporal
sampling, so not only
sampling along a
spatial gradient,
but sampling the same locations
at repeated time intervals.
And we just haven't
done that yet.
- And yes, related to
that, that's a question
I had in mind.
So the temperatures now are
just so extreme in all parts
of the countries.
You would predict that that's
going to have some impact.
You just don't know
what the impact
is because-- that's right.
So the idea is to baseline
these white clover, so to speak.
And then go after them after
extreme weather changes
or, I mean, is there
a biorepository
with all this information?
Where do you keep
this information?
- Where do we keep the data on
the white clover specifically?
Well, right now it's being held
primarily by our collaborators
or in our freezer at the
University of Toronto.
To get a better sense
of how quickly some
of these populations
can respond,
it would require going
back into the field,
collecting more tissue
from these populations,
and doing that over
enough years that we
could get a sense of
what is the change
in the frequency of hydrogen
cyanide from one year
to the next.
- Right.
So you would have some data
on the impact of moisture
and humidity on that phenotype.
- Yeah, but really
right now only
from remote sensing or
whatever regional variables
that we could get access to.
One of the downsides of
satellite data, of course,
is that it's only
part of the picture.
It's only environmental data.
I suspect that some
of the things that
are driving these patterns are
actually species interactions,
changes in the amount
of insect damage
as you move from
outside to inside
the city, which we know is
more important at southern
latitudes, and could explain
some of these stronger clines.
But of course, you can't get
insect-plant interactions
from satellite data.
And so hopefully I
could convince somebody
to pay to send me down there
and collect some of that data.
- Well, that's great.
I'm going to close it to the
five-minute question round,
and then we're
going to open it up
to a full Q&A, 15 to 20 minutes.
And I invite all the
speakers back up, please--
Sriram, Alicia, Katie.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]